all right we will get started mike
please
hey lebron it's mike trudell back in l.a
what did you think accounted for that
the difference in the d in the third
quarter and the fourth quarter
and the just how how much there uh you
know houston of course 41 points in the
third and then that completely changed
what did you guys do um i mean we came
out in the third quarter we gave up back
to back to back threes
i was just straight breakdowns and uh
once you allow a team like that to get
going then it's hard to reel them back
in so
that's what that's that was the result
of the third quarter got an opportunity
to
you know catch our catch our breath you
know from the third quarter to the
fourth quarter
fortunately and we was able to turn the
ship and uh
and make the adjustments um to combat
what we did in the third quarter and uh
be positive in the fourth
you really asserted yourself to start
that fourth quarter going to the rim for
the dunk then you got up in transition
what were you noticing about the way
houston was defending uh that that had
you uh take that path to start the
fourth quarter
no it's just for me um i mean i started
the fourth quarter eighties on the bench
and uh you know my teammates looked at
me to try to be aggressive either giving
myself shots or getting my teammate
shots and uh
you know i got an opportunity to see a
couple seams able to attack the rim
um you know and also find a couple guys
um as well so
you know like i said every possession
dictates uh different results and uh i
was able to capitalize on a few of them
lebron it's dave plus-minus doesn't
always tell the story
for an individual player but tonight it
seemed to reflect rondo's game he was a
plus 28 in 28 minutes
is only a second game in like six months
um
what'd he give you tonight and um did
you see any
difference in his approach in game two
versus game one
yeah i think he was just um you know
extremely aggressive not only offensive
but defensively
um taking the challenge on james um you
know taking the challenge on whoever he
was guarding um
just trying to you know just trying to
lead i mean that's what that's what doe
is he's a leader
and uh for us to have him back in the
postseason um
it's a key for our team he comes in he
pushes the tempo
he gets guys involved um you know and it
doesn't always show up in the stat sheet
with doe
you know the intangibles that he does
offensively and defensively
his nose is always around the ball and
uh he just makes plays for us and
tonight was another example that
uh allison hello
um i think we asked you a lot before
this series
on how much you guys have to kind of
compose your will with your side
then of course you go small tonight
played very effectively that way how
much confidence do you have and
the flexibility the roster has the
lineups
that take any kind of approach well we
built the team to be able to play
in different ways and um you know be
able to play big first teams be able to
play small
be able to play um in between um you
know we
we built that from the beginning and uh
we have that um
always had that in our toolbox and
tonight was an example of that being
able to go to that
um smoove was um markieff sorry
might not know his nickname uh uh keith
was um
spectacular off the bench giving us that
um that instant offense but just his
grit
uh you know we love having him on the
floor but he was unbelievable for us in
that second quarter
and uh and everyone else who came in
like you said you know doe um
you know ac cools those guys just came
in and just gave us a big boost
[Music]
i mean for sure i mean you know you
definitely love having supporters in the
building but you also see me
yelling over on that side when no one is
over there so it hasn't changed for me
um you know it's definitely always great
to see familiar faces you know people
that you know that has been there
along the grind with you and uh
throughout post season runs for me
personally as well but
um just having our um you know some of
our family here and then having some of
our laker uh laker um
personnel uh people in the front office
and things of that nature over there um
you know it's great for us and we just
try to you know
at the same time you get to maintain the
main thing and try to execute but you
know the emotions are
are definitely great when you're making
plays out there and you're doing it for
your brothers your teammates and uh you
know your family and friends as well
why don't i decide not to have my kids
to come here because nothing for them to
do
i mean i got a 16 year old i mean he's
gonna sit in the bubble and do what
um i got a 13 year old he's going to do
what
um and then my five-year-old girl
there's nothing for her to do here the
park is not open
i mean only so many times she can go to
the pool you know
my kids are too adventurous and and and
they love to do so much stuff it's
it makes no sense for them to be here
there's nothing for them to do here
go outside come back in go outside come
back in
they can stay in la and you know
they're great there's literally nothing
for them to do here this is not a kid
for any place
to be honest one more question with will
all right yes one more uh melissa roland
hey lebron you talked a lot about the
rocket speed in the last game
um did you guys adjust to that the way
you were hoping that uh
that your team would tonight yeah like i
said after game one
sometimes you need one game to be able
to understand the speed that they play
with
and i think we adjusted from game one to
game two extremely fast team
they have um you know everyone keeps
talking about the small ball but their
speed
and their activity defensively and
offensively is something that can catch
you off guard
um you know from you know like a game
one situation
and uh we got a feel for that and we
understand how hard
how much uh you know you know every
possession
and how much scrambling and how much
running and how much pace and how
physical
you know the game is going to be versus
10 because they're very good extremely
good
no matter who's on the floor so we did a
good job of that tonight
all right thanks lebron
my next in the room
all right well we're back whenever
you're ready
all right uh dave miniman is going to
get us started
anthony you guys had a 21 point lead in
the first half
and the rockets made their run came all
the way back and took the lead back
do you learn anything or is it almost
better to have that happen than just
run through and hold that lead the whole
way can this benefit you more
moving forward the way it went down um
no we want to for sure keep the lead um
you know they're a
great three-point shooting team you know
moving the ball around getting the shots
that they want and they surround it
you know james and russ was great
three-point shooters who make shots so
uh you know they came down that third
quarter and got hot quick
um you know and then we just tried to
come back to run knowing that was that
running we try to make a run of our own
so
you know with this team they're never
out of the game
because of the way they shoot the ball
hey anthony mike trudell back in l.a
have you noticed a difference
in from where you're getting your shots
when you're in with the small lineup
like as the
you know quote unquote five versus if
you're playing the four
just given how unique defensively is
there a difference in you from where
you're getting your looks
um i think they are around the same area
um just trying to play closer to the
basket and play a little quicker
but i think the shots are are the same
uh
you know a lot of mid-range and things
that's close to the basket so
you know trying to stay it's close to
the best it was possible
hey anthony it's bill orem when when you
guys go into the fourth quarter down by
two
are you how present is it in your mind
that
what an o2 deficit in this series would
potentially mean
are you thinking about it along those
lines are you more focused on kind of
what's directly
in front of you uh we thinking about
what's in front of us
you know our job is it's a wonderful
quarter at that point
you know we're down two and they had a
huge run a third
and what we're thinking about going in
the fourth quarter um
you know we're not you know in that
situation thinking you know we can be
down till we lose this game
you know our mind says how do we win
this game and you know we came out with
a defensive mindset
but getting back to that defensive
mindset we had in the first half
and you know limit their their three
attempts and also
when we get stopped running transition
play our style of basketball and let's
get up and down the floor and
we was able to convert on that in the
fourth quarter and help us get the win
um you guys had a good run
i know you went off to work
um we have a veteran group you know guys
stay ready
you know marquee been in the league for
a while those been elite for a while
um and these guys you know trust their
work
they come in and and work every day and
um
you know putting the time so they better
their craft and when they get on the
floor
two guys who aren't afraid of anything
afraid of big shots um
aren't afraid of guard you know the best
player
so when they come in the game uh you
know they're ready to play
and they stay ready and the show tonight
and we're going to need those guys for
the remainder of this series
will anyone on your end uh yes i can
take two more
uh andy hey anthony um from your
perspective defensively
how much of a difference was there with
you guys in the first second and fourth
quarter when you were really
holding down houston and they were
struggling to score versus that third
in terms of execution versus just them
making shots
uh in the third quarter our rotation was
kind of bad
um you know we wouldn't get out getting
out to their shooters
and kind of got them back in their
rhythm um
you know in the first second and fourth
we were kind of you know our rotation
was going it was on point and we were
closing out together she was making them
drive the basketball
um you know and shoot two so they came
out
very explosive you know from three in
that third quarter and get back in the
game
and they got a little rhythm so we try
to you know cut their
water off and uh make sure that uh
you know they beat us another way they
ended over the top
last one from me michael duarte
hey d after game one you had said that
you guys need to attack that small
lineup you did a good job of that you
outscored them in the paint
and you shot half as many threes as they
did unlike game one
my question for you is when they get hot
like that in that third quarter and
they're hitting their threes
how do you guys not overreact and try to
like shoot threes back to kind of
counter their run
uh and stay within yourself i'll play
offs all the basketball
you know we we can't you know get down
that they make shots they're a great
three points from the team they shoot a
ton of three they're gonna make some
our job is to get it out the rim and
push um
you know and when we do that i think we
had a couple plays where
they made a shot we got it out push it
ahead and i know
one player could've got a dunk so our
job is to just keep
you know pushing the tempo uh miss or
make and we were able to do that tonight
but
um you know we know they're trying to
close us out
um all the three and run us off the
three-point line and you know we got to
be able to
you know redrive the basketball and and
get open looks and most of our threes
tonight
uh were pretty much open you know guys
took their time and knocked down shots
you know some guys got hot but we didn't
we didn't settle for threes
we made sure we attacked the basket and
was able to get
some easy looks at the rim which opened
the floor up even more for us
all right